In this lesson, we'll take a look at viewing CPU draw threads as well as looking at Unreal
Insights.
So let's get started.
So the CPU draw threads, what goes on here when you actually run this display, it handles
most of the occlusion processes.
It decides what is visible or not.
And it'll do this in real time as you move your camera around.
It happens per object, not per triangle.
You'll look at your distance calling.
There's a frustrum calling as well as your occlusion calling being looked at.
The console for that is stat init views here.
And you'll see also in stat menu pull down, you can also access it if you don't want to
use the console command.
So you can also grab it there.
So if we go into the next slide here, you'll see it is broken down into two different sections.
The first one being the cycle counters.
Here you'll see the view visibility.
That's the amount of the frame time spent to process actor visibility queries.
Occlusion call, the amount of frame time spent to query the scene for the actors within the
view frustrum that were occluded by other actors.
We have the frustrum call.
And we also have decompress occlusion.
Now there's a few more that we've added as you go through here and you can actually see
what's going on looking at your milliseconds, what may be causing a slowdown in your system.
That's really why you want to look at this.
You're seeing what the CPU is doing to calculate things.
It's almost like you're going in between the calculations between the CPU and the GPU final
output.
So you can actually see where there may be a hold down in the system.
The second section looks at the counters here and we have the process, primitives and frustrum
call primitives, occluded primitives, occluded queries, visible dynamic primitives and visible
static mesh primitives.
Now if we go to the last one here, which is our cycle counters, you'll see I just gave
you a few here.
There's quite a bit in here so I didn't break them all down.
But I gave you some of the key ones to look at for the most part.
And you can go in here and see how things are being digested overall.
But these are some of the key factor ones if your milliseconds you're noticing that things
are taking a bit longer.
Now this will take an account anything with your CPU that's mainly being digested and
running into some problems.
And this will also account if your blueprints are running into here, some issues or your
C++ maybe you made a particular plug-in that's working in your system.
You can actually see if those queries are also messing with the other things that it's
calling upon.
It's basically looking at the middle of the chain and trying to see where those holdups
might be.
So the next one we're going to take a look at here is also you can look at your draw
calls here using a stat RHI.
These can also be punched in the console command and it will pull it up.
And again it will be like an overlay in your system and as you move your camera around
it will tell you exactly give you an update of what's going on with your minimum and maximum
pull on your system here like milliseconds wise what is actually causing things to go
to a crawl.
Currently Unreal has a dynamic instance scene system making it easier to have more items
in the scene.
If the actor shares the same geo and material and this is why we talked about this in the
beginning it gets drawn as one draw call.
To see how it works you can use the command mesh draw command dynamic instancing 0 for
off and 1 for on.
So this is all up to you how you want to process that.
Now if we go briefly into Unreal you'll see that we're actually running at a pretty high
frame rate.
In the beginning I think just things were calling and things were getting into in the
system.
It was a little bit slow but we're actually at a pretty good frame rate right now.
So in our scene if I go up here and I click on here you'll see show frames per second.
We're running at 7670 frames per second.
If you do get this landscape error because this is a bit of a bug currently what you
can do is actually hit play.
All that play for a second.
I don't even have to necessarily run around and then hit escape to get out of there.
And typically this should go away but it looks like it doesn't want to go away.
But that's usually how you would get rid of that.
So you'll see we're going at a really good frame rate here.
Let's actually run those stats here.
So let me get rid of that trace stop for a second.
We'll reference that just a bit.
We're going to go to a stat and it views.
There we go.
Now we're looking at our CPU draw thread here.
And again you can move into your scene and take a look at where things may be a little
bit odd in the hold up here.
Now again these are just multiple tools we give you at Epic Games to be able to work
with these things.
You don't have to necessarily use them but we want to give you options in here.
Let me hit enter to get rid of that one.
And let's go and run that other one.
Let's do that stat.
RHI.
And again you'll see this one here.
Take a look again at our GPU memory pool.
And it's giving us an average letting us know how things are being drawn.
Triangle, triangular wise.
Looking at the triangles.
I can't talk.
But you'll actually be able to get a good analysis of what's going on and millisecond
wise where your hold ups might be.
Now let's take a look at another way to analyze your scene using Unreal Insights.
This is using the trace system.
Let's talk a bit about that and how that works.
And how using the Unreal Insights is actually pretty efficient overall.
There used to be other systems such as session front end but now it's a little bit fractured
and there's some aspects of it that are deprecated so it doesn't quite work the same as it used
to.
Now you can't analyze things and check for bugs kind of but you won't be able to analyze
them on the same type of level that you get here with Unreal Insights as you used to.
So data here is collected from a runtime using the trace system that we've developed.
That Unreal Insights will look at the trace server and look at the application and look
at the game.
So the structured event logging, it's high performance, low overhead.
And what it means by low overhead, you actually have this works in within a reel.
It actually works as an EXE standalone type of function inside of Unreal.
So you don't have to worry about having the editor in the background and giving you kind
of bad data because things are being digested as you're in the editor at the same time as
trying to check for any kind of problems going on in your scene slowdowns.
So it acts as a standalone and works actually pretty efficiently.
It can be activated again as you see from the bottom menu there and I'll run you through
that in just a bit and I'll talk a little bit about the menu in Unreal as well as look
at some of the points of the menu that I have in our slides.
So again, how the system works.
We have the game editor, we have a trace API.
This is going to be looking at whatever host directory you can choose.
It's up to you.
I'll point those things out to you.
You can run a trace file if you want to via console command.
Heck, you can even run a trace file in your Windows console if you want to.
It's up to you.
But for the most part, you can run it via Unreal and it'll act as an individual EXE if you
wish.
So you have several options here.
So Insights works just like an EXE and you'll see there's a session browser UI here.
That's again acting like an EXE.
It's almost like a one to one.
We have a trace server.
You can run the trace unrealtraceserver.exe or Trace Store here, which is the equivalent
inside of the interface.
And it will use a UTrace file that it's going to read and write to.
And eventually when you launch, Unreal Insights is going to analyze things and your Insights
viewer, Unreal Insights EXE is going to trace and analyze things overall.
And all these things are kind of built into the UI now, which is actually kind of nice.
Before you would run the EXE, it would run the UI by itself, but now we have it built
into the editor.
So it acts like an EXE.
So it actually is pretty efficient.
So here are some things to consider.
So Unreal 5 Trace Center for Enabled Channels is catched and the Always On buffers.
So we have trail tracing plus import events.
So it's really going to be there for you to actually look at where your milliseconds are
being hit.
What is bogging down your game?
Also slash, say you're sending things to the wall via ICVFX, you're like, man, I don't
understand what's going on.
You can actually trace that, but not only can you trace that, you can actually, on one
level GPU, you can also do CPU.
So you can do both at the same time.
So you'll see command line arguments here that you can choose once, you can choose where
to put it, and you can choose where that file is going to go to, per se.
And it will be sent to a trace server or to a file.
And again, this is up to you how you choose that within your pipeline, working with your
IT team.
Do you have a server or are you all analyzing a particular scene that everybody can access?
It's up to you.
Are you a small indie house or it may not be as big to grab it, but you can actually
still place it in a certain area.
And then you can also use that data.
You can grab that scene to analyze it from your desk if you needed to.
So Trace is a structured login framework for tracing instrumentation events from a running
process.
The Unreal Trace server is run in the background as a single server instance and can be shared
between multiple projects or branches.
And this is what I mean by that.
So it is a lightweight program that has minimal impact on performance and does not include,
a user interface.
So that can also be run here.
You can do and you'll see it's launched by separate server process executable.
Unreal Trace server.exe located in the engine binaries, Win64 directory folder.
So running this trace system, we can run it through Unreal Insights, but also if you needed
to, you can run things individually if you even want it cleaner.
But overall, we have it pretty set pretty nicely using Unreal Insights to be able to
actually work really well.
But again, the Unreal Trace server can be placed and even isolating things a bit more
to be able to analyze your overall scene.
So the Trace system.
The Trace server has two functionalities.
The Trace recorder listens on port 1981 for incoming trace in connections and records
the live trace stream.
Number two, the second point here, the Trace stores the recorded traces as a file to a path
like users.
Users API data, local engine, common Unreal Trace store.
It watches this folder for changes and exposes a list of available traces to Unreal Insights.
So this trace is being accessed through Unreal Insights.
Unreal Insights uses this Trace system.
But again, like I said on the previous slide, you can run the Trace system by itself.
I don't really know in what cases you might do that.
That's really up to you.
You may just want to isolate things a bit more if you want to.
But I liked being able to use the Unreal Insights and accessing that information because then
you have the full interface to be able to filter out what the data that you need and
what you need to look at.
So just keep those things in mind.
All right, let's talk a little bit about the interface here.
And then we're also going to go back and forth between Unreal.
I'm going to pop into Unreal and then we'll go back and reference these slides.
So ignore my error here on the top here.
This is a bit of a bug.
Usually you hit play, like I mentioned earlier, and you run around and hit escape.
It usually goes away.
So in this case, it doesn't want to and that's fine.
So we find our trace here information.
We can even start a trace individually without pulling up Unreal Insights to make sure everything's
in order.
We could just quickly run a trace if you want to.
Again, you can still look at it through Unreal Insights, which is nice.
It's basically just jumping the gun and not doing it through the interface.
You go straight to the button that does the trace.
Now you can set into a file if you needed to or trace store, which is the directory that you choose.
So in here, I'm going to choose my Unreal Insights.
So I can show you a little bit of what I'm talking about.
So in here, we have a series of traces that we already ran.
Now you're probably wondering, why are some of these pink?
Well, that's because earlier versions of Unreal, this wouldn't always
stop like what you wanted it to.
You would do a trace stop or in this case, if I go to the output log at the up arrow,
you'll see a trace stop.
It used to be used to be able to do stop trace and trace stop.
And there would be a little bit of a delay.
But in 5.3, we've kind of weeded some of that out.
So that's less of an issue.
So let's go and pull this up again.
So again, it's going to give you a full log directory of all the traces that you've run.
Now you can choose platforms if you need to.
There's an app name here, config.
There's some very minimal type of viewing filtering you could do and versions of Unreal.
So all that is available there too.
So what I can do here is also I want to make sure first up I want to check my connection.
Am I going to a server?
What is that IP address?
What is the initial channels?
And you want to check if you can connect.
So you see we are successfully connecting, which is great.
And that allows us to do a trace.
Now once you've created a trace again, you can open a trace.
This is doing a live trace currently.
If I double click on it, it's going to show me the process as it is running.
And let me open this up a little bit so you can see what's going on.
So now it's running a trace.
I do advise moving around your scene if you can.
And that way you can see if the player or your camera in ICVFX is giving you a bit of a slowdown.
Let's go back to Unreal Insights here.
We can see that's running.
Let's go and stop that trace.
So I'm going to go to my output log.
I'm going to go ahead and delete this and hit the up arrow.
And we're going to go to stop or trace dot stop.
And I'm going to hit enter.
Now I'll go back to Unreal Insights.
It should have stopped.
Yay, it did.
And that's good.
We can now zoom in on any areas of data that we need to.
And you can highlight and see, hey, you know, what is the issues that are occurring with my scene?
You also have down below here, we have a log.
Now you can filter all of these if you just want to keep it a little bit cleaner.
Like say, I don't want to look at my frames.
I don't want to look at my timing.
I can turn that off.
I don't want to look at my timers.
I can look at my callers.
Say I don't want to see all those in here per count.
If I wanted to, instant count, number of selected items in here, you can double click these at any time within your listing here.
Let's go to GPU specifically.
Turn off CPU.
And I'll say I'll look at my lights.
I'll double click on my lights.
It'll give you a color code of what it is in the scene.
You'll see there's an info here as I slide over.
Tells me the ID for the lights, the GPU, and it gives you a mini rundown of what's going on here.
Now I can go in here and isolate data if I want to.
I can zoom in on a particular area of data and I can double click on that area.
So let's look at a spiking area.
This is a little spiky here.
So let's go on.
What's the issue here?
So I'm going to click on this game frame here and see what it is.
And I can zoom in on it if I want to and analyze what's going on.
And Unreal's giving me a section of data that's being processed for that particular region here.
It's actually kind of nice.
So this is really great to be able to get a handle on this.
And then you'll see the callers come up here.
Now they are populating.
So again, we have the log two.
This will tell me and give me a little bit more data of what's going on.
It tells me what my console commands are, where my errors might be occurring.
In here, I typed in a trace stop versus a stop trace.
I think that's always re-invert those.
I did a stop trace versus a trace stop.
So, but my log is letting me know that that was put in incorrectly and letting me know
any errors that may be occurring.
So again, you have the session information here tells you where things are,
how things are being handled.
And then we also have the timing insights here.
So all of this can be analyzed and I can move these around if I need to.
And I can highlight regions and you'll see this come up and give me my caller information.
I'll look at my direct rendering there, my shadows in here if I need to.
And this is based on my highlights.
So I'm going to click on this, the bypass here, and it's going to pull up the callers again.
Show me what's going on with it milliseconds where I'm being hit and say, hey, lumen reflections.
Is that giving me trouble?
I can see that it's actually not too bad and gives you a full analysis of things.
And again, you can choose CPU and GPU if you need to and you can walk through that.
So let's talk a little bit more about the interface here in the slides.
And I'll give you a quick walkthrough here of how you can analyze things and get up
and running a bit faster.
You can see here again, it says where, who and what are you analyzing?
If we go here, you can run Unreal Insights via the Unreal EXE.
We talked about that.
If you choose to, it's up to you.
You can do it through Windows console commands if you need.
Both are very valid and Unreal has it nice and cleanly in the menu,
which works like an EXE if you need it to work.
So you'll see the interface here a little bit more broken down for you.
Talking about how to use this again, there's a trace store and there's a connection.
And also what and where we talked about that.
So I broke this down for you in the slides so you can actually get a little more
acquainted with it.
Note for games, you can run Insights and keep it open while running your game
for a performance trace.
When doing so, you can run Insights via EXE or via a command prompt.
So you can do that through the Windows command prompt.
So emphasize on that again.
If you wanted to analyze that in an actual build.
So again, the interface breaking it down here, again, we saw the log.
We saw how you can look at the data up close.
We see that you can look at the timing panel overall.
All these things can be filtered the way that you need.
And again, you can look at GPU, CPU, and then look at the callers based on what
you have selected.
So here are some of the commands to work with this.
We have trace enable, trace disable, trace pause, and trace resume.
You have trace send, you have trace file, and you also have trace stop.
And then we also can look at your trace status, where things are at.
And it'll give you a quick brief breakdown there of how things are.
So how to read it, groups.
You can also group and isolate data.
They may be at times a refresh issue requiring you to close in real and
unreal listeners temporarily.
This is particularly for ICB effects or switch for it to get insights to reopen
and sometimes populate data.
Now this is less of a problem with 5.3, but it was a problem with earlier
versions of Unreal where sometimes things would get a little bit delayed.
It also may fail to execute inside of the editor and the EXE will need to be used
if you ever run into that.
But it should not be a problem at this time with 5.3.
But be aware if that occurs, that's a solution for it.
Unreal Insights in Unreal now works like an EXE, like I said before.
So again, it actually is nice and clean and has a nice little standalone
workflow specifically for ICB effects that works great.
But again, you can run it as an EXE or Windows console if you want to run it
while you're playing your packaged game.
Here's a few more links here to help you get on that vein of thought here,
working with Unreal Insights.
And a little YouTube video we had a while back about testing and optimizing
your content.
Thanks again with this one.
In the next video, we're going to look at optimization visualizers when it comes
to analyzing your scene.